[Music]
Stanford University
good evening everybody
I'm Charles young current Dean of
continuing studies and it's my pleasure
to welcome you tonight to the first in
our second year of the series pioneers
in science these events celebrate the
lives and accomplishments of Stanford
faculty members who have received Nobel
prizes National medals of science or
technology and MacArthur fellowships
subsequent events in this year's lineup
include anthropologist Bill Durham or
received a MacArthur Fellowship coming
on November 4th that's the second of our
fall events in winter Nobel laureate
Doug Ashraf and National Medal of
Science awardee Stanley Cohen and then
in spring the two final events of the
year National Medal of Science awardee
pets soubise followed by Nobel laureate
Roger Kornberg it's quite a lineup and
as you'll see tonight each of these
events is introduced by the awardees and
awardees colleague who is eminently
distinguished as well so you get eight
Stanford distinguished scientists in
this year's lineup special thanks to Pat
Devaney the series founder and director
Pat is former associate dean of research
and director of the Office of Science
outreach to Greg priest the series
research director to seen Masuda our
events and communications manager who's
undoubtedly out in the lobby and to Paul
Costello whom you'll see on stage
tonight and a special thanks to our
financial co-sponsor of the Stanford
Historical Society and before I say a
few words to kick off tonight's event
I'm going to put in a plug for the
Historical Society the brochures for the
society are out on the table in the
you do not need to have a formal
affiliation with Stanford to belong all
you need to do is care about the
university its past its present its
future its mission and in addition to
the brochure I hope there is still some
of these flyers for the Society's first
public program of the year it's going to
be an interesting program what does the
Board of Trustees actually do something
those of us who have been here for 25
years not quite sure about but we'll get
an answer on October 27th from Leslie
Hume the current chair of the board and
berth McMurtry a Past Chair and again
this event is open to members and
non-members alike October 27th 5:15 in
Annenberg auditorium and if you want
more information you can find the
stanford historical society website very
easily i'm sure we are pleased and
honored to have professor William F
sharp the Stanko professor of finance
emeritus in 1990 Nobel laureate in
economics with us tonight in
conversation with Paul Costello the
executive director of communication and
public affairs in the Stanford School of
Medicine as is our practice tonight's
program will be introduced by a
distinguished colleague in the honorees
field following the introduction Paul
and professor sharp will join in
conversation for about 45 minutes after
which we'll open it up to the audience
there are microphones in the aisle as
you can see and we ask that you please
do use the microphone so everybody can
hear the question you may notice that
this event is also being videotaped you
were if you choose to pose a question
only your voice will be recorded not
your image because the cameras will stay
focused on stage finally please turn off
your cellphone's okay so tonight is my
prolific privilege to introduce James
Van Horn the AP Giannini professor of
banking and finance emeritus in the
Graduate School of Business here at
Stanford who will in turn introduce
professor
professor Van Horn came to Stanford in
1965 where his teaching and research
have focused on corporate finance
mergers and acquisitions corporate
restructuring fixed income securities
and government and nonprofit debt
financing he was the very first
recipient of the distinguished Teaching
Award from the MBAs and received it
again in 1997 quite an honor to be
picked twice for that award he's the
author of five books many articles three
of those books financial management and
policy financial market rates and flows
and fundamentals of financial management
are used all over the United States and
internationally and two of them are in
their 12th editions which is quite
handsome among his many honors and
leadership positions in the world of
finance Jim Van Horne served as the
president of the American Finance
Association and as Deputy Assistant
Secretary of the US Treasury please join
me in welcoming Jim Van Horn
Thank You charlie
it's been my privilege to have known and
to know Bill sharp for some 40 years and
this evening to be able to reflect on
his remarkable impact on the Nance
academics and on investment managers
worldwide the zest with which he
approaches research and for that matter
really life in general can best be
summarized by a quotation from Mark
Twain and I quote you'll be more
disappointed by the things you didn't do
than by the ones you did so throw off
your bow lines and sail away from safe
harbor Bills of sale or incidentally
catch the wind in your sails explore
dream discover bill is always exploring
dreaming and discovering new things
perhaps he is best known for the capital
asset pricing model known simply as the
CAPM this model is based on a notion
that security prices are largely
determined by investors who are hold
multiple securities that is they are
well diversified the important risk to
them then is the risk that cannot be
diversified away in market equilibrium a
security will be expected to provide a
return commensurate with its unavoidable
or systemic risk the other portion of
total volatility can be eliminated by
the well diversified investor and
therefore doesn't really enter into the
securities equilibrium price now the
unavoidable risk of a security and a
portfolio of securities is captured
mathematically by the sensitivity of its
return with the return of the overall
market the overall security market the
S&P 500 often being used for that
purpose the beta closely associated with
Bill of a security is simply the slope
of the relationship between these two
returns that for the individual security
and that for the overall market first
published 45 years ago in the Journal of
Finance the CPA the CAPM gradually first
but then an accelerated fashion
literally shook the academic and invest
communities it's an equilibrium theory
which allows the security to be priced
on a risk-adjusted return basis and in
the corporate world for a cost of equity
capital to be determined
now as often occurs with a game-changing
idea the CAPM has had its detractors
some of whom have argued that data is
dead however the model has stood the
test of time beta is resilient and the
CAPM is still the standard that has
taught in business schools worldwide
bill has had a very large has left
really a very large imprint on how
investment performance is measured and
how it is evaluated early on in 1963 in
connection with this movement he
published a sophisticated mathematical
algorithm for determining the efficient
set of securities with the highest
expected return relative to volatility
as measured by the standard deviation
this was a start of an assault clearly
an assault on subjective and anecdotal
measures of investment performance which
occurred in the pre Sharpe era
performance now is measured
quantitatively a simple example of an a
quantitative approach is the Sharpe
ratio widely used today and really in
the lexicon of every money manager it's
defined as a portfolios actual return in
excess of the risk-free rate frequently
the Treasury bill rate divided by the
portfolio standard deviation returned a
reward to bearable I'm sorry a rewards a
variability ratio if you will first set
forth by Bill some 40 years ago he was
an early and a strong advocate of
investment performance being judged
relative to an appropriate benchmark
it's not enough to say that a portfolio
manager has earned a positive return the
C or she provided return an excess of
what is provided by the benchmark
portfolio style analysis where style of
investment strategies such as
large capitalization growth mid-cap
value quantitative quantum Oh as much of
his emphasis day to bill be in its early
champion one thing that style analysis
does is provide a quantitative approach
to finding an appropriate benchmark in
addition to a number of articles and
many many talks Bill's highly respected
investments textbook further these ideas
over the years the objectivity by which
investment managers are evaluated as to
performance has increased many fold
thanks in no small part in the
missionary zeal of Bill sharp there's a
Chinese saying that a bicycle never
stops it only falls down when you stop
bill never stops even after is early
acclaim as one of the most creative and
stimulating financial economists of the
twentieth century though he never
received full credit for the idea he
really was the first to set for a
binomial approached option pricing this
approach is the most widely used method
today for valuing options on stocks
options on bonds and mortgage backed
securities on commodities and on other
instruments this type of idea has
received a Nobel Prize in the past
needless to say for option pricing
another example is the creativity is the
application of option pricing to deposit
insurance the notion is that there is an
incentive for management of a depository
institution to increase volatility
through investing and riskier assets and
or increasing leverage or taking highly
risky derivative positions if things
turn out favorably management through
bonuses and equity compensation benefits
handsomely if the bet doesn't pay off
the downside is bounded at zero and the
institution is turned over to the
deposit insure usually the taxpayer is
backing that so heads we win tails the
taxpayer and not we as management losses
this concept is a pible to a number of
financial situations and really I think
explains much of the behavior
in the mid part of this decade when debt
was price of cheaply in the marketplace
gambling with other people's money
a bandit branch of Bill's family
emanates from the state of Maine in a
small town there called Bucksport which
is in the Penobscot Bay region of the
state there's a story of an older
gentleman in that town who on his front
porches rocker was interviewed by a
reporter from the Bangor Daily News and
he was asked if he had lived in
Bucksport all his life to which the
gentleman replied not yet and so it is
with our honoree this evening if he were
asked a question have you done research
all your life well most people in my
vintage no longer do serious research
this is not the case with Bill he keeps
plowing ahead his present work on
retirement finance is creative as well
as novel it offers much insight into
investment in spending behavior both
normative and prescriptive for people
planning for retirement and this you
might expect from the creativity really
appalled sage through his every vein not
surprisingly he's received a lot of
professional recognition for his work
the Nobel Prize of course but a number
of best paper and outstanding
contribution to the field Awards and he
also serves yes served as president of
American Finance Association from a
personal standpoint I and my colleagues
at Stanford Business School have
benefited probably the most from our
interaction with Bill he has been a
superb colleague full of ideas in
stimulation on a host of economic and
finance topics and this transcends to
PhD students that we've had in finance
in the past it truly has been a
privilege to have him as a colleague and
as a friend well I could say much more
about Bill like an Egyptian mummy I'm
strapped for time this evening so I'm
going to turn it over to the premier
event of this evening namely a
discussion with Bill chart
thank you did you know about buck sport
well I've never heard that story my I
will tell you by ninety nine year old
great uncle who was a mailman sleigh in
the winter etc Bachelor chopped his own
wood was determined that he would make
it to a hundred at which point he would
not pay his income tax because he you
know I used to say Frankie well I don't
know what we're coming to makes me
tremble he was very conservative and he
didn't make it to a hundred but I think
that's what kept him going at least till
ninety nine so that may have been I have
no notion Jim by the way do you see why
Jim is and was one of the best teachers
that the Stanford Business School ever
ever had I wanted to start with asking
you about when we met a few weeks ago
you said that the family's business your
family's business was education and that
you gained your love of learning through
your parents and and you told really
great pointed stories about your parents
can you share with us how their parents
instilled that learning in you that love
learning and if I can remember what I
said a couple of weeks ago my family was
impacted as you might imagine I was born
in 34 by the second war so my parents
came to education after my stepfather in
kind of midlife my father had been a
student in the classics more or less at
Harvard that's been his year abroad on
scholarship sampling life in Europe
primarily and then had gone back to
Harvard working in the personnel office
he was in the National Guard and so a
year before Pearl Harbor he was called
active duty we moved to Texas they have
to Pearl Harbor to Vallejo here there
and everywhere he after the war went to
work for the Veterans Administration in
San Francisco
in personnel and started teaching at
Golden Gate than college and I'm
delighted I have some students and
colleague from Golden Gate here and then
in mid-career in midlife took a PhD in
education at Stanford he then headed a
small school in the Midwest and then
came back to Golden Gate as president my
mother during the second war was in
retailing and then after the war she had
a degree from pembroke went back to
Pomona and got a masters and an
education certificate of credential and
ended up as a an elementary school
principal and my stepfather in
mid-career
having worked at the County garage took
the bar exam by teaching himself out of
correspondence courses and became an
assistant DA and a public defender so he
was not in education per se but they all
partook of it you mentioned the war and
also when we spoke a few weeks ago you
talked about the imprint of the war had
upon you the imprint that the war had
upon your France and but also the
imprint that the war had upon education
in America well I think I guess perhaps
the thing you may be alluding to when we
moved to Vallejo my father was in the
anti-aircraft to defend the shipyard it
was impossible to get housing this huge
influx of military into the Bay Area and
the school was on double and at times
triple sessions so the teachers would
teach one group of kids in the morning
and then another totally different group
in the afternoon I moved many times and
I was ahead two grades and I was ahead
one grade and then I was ahead again
then I was behind I guess the thing I
remembered most was that when I moved to
Riverside in Southern California I was
in fourth grade and it was a spring and
they tested me on my multiplication
tables this is a little bit ironic and
it turned out in Vallejo they only went
through ten which seems fairly sensible
to me now in Riverside for some reason
they went through twelve and I have not
memorized my 11s and 12s so I flunked
and I was made to repeat fourth grade
for my sins
doing great home so everything about it
was it was a it was a pretty crazy time
and of course a very tragic time the
other thing that you couldn't stand the
sight of blood yeah and your mother
wanted you to be a physician a doctor
but that wasn't gonna be the cards and
and economics was what did you love
about a cop and when you spoke about it
to me you spoke about it very
passionately and the word that was used
earlier was a zest and you spoke about
it really very deeply well in my time
there was no such thing as economics in
high school so I have no notion when I
started college at Berkley actually what
economics was and and my mother did want
me to be a doctor and I didn't really
like chemistry or physics all that much
nothing personal my friends in the
audience so to make a long story short I
transferred to UCLA where I thought a
business major would be super and I took
two courses beginning micro economics
and accounting which was really
bookkeeping absolutely loathed and
despite accounting but I thought
economics was I don't know what the word
probably swell then but and I would say
it was cool I just thought it was lovely
how you can make these perfectly
plausible little assumptions about
behavior and choice and then aggregate
and get these unexpected results as to
how things work in the larger economy
under those conditions at least
and I like the poetry of it I know it
seems odd to associate poetry with
economics but I do what does it mean the
poetry of it I think just aesthetically
appealing it's you know you sparse
assumptions nice little grime varying
the graphical so I love the graphs and
you know you get the intersection and
then something comes along and there's a
there's a less oil and you know and the
price goes up in order to ration it and
all these things that you don't see when
you're buying and selling but
nonetheless happen in the larger economy
when you put it all together so I
thought it was aesthetically appealing I
thought it was practical I had no notion
of how I was going to earn a living but
I changed instantly to an economics
major you actually fail the job of
getting a job as a bank is a bank I did
when I was which was a good thing yeah
when I was finishing my senior year I
went out to interview when I thought
well what am I gonna do with an
economics degree I suppose work for a
bank and I interviewed two or three Bank
people in LA and typically the interview
would go well hmm I see you have very
good grades and initially not knowing
better I would say yes
yes I do naturally and and then they'd
say well why don't you go on to graduate
school instead of wanting to work in my
bank and one of them finally told me
it's no it's not the a students that we
like to hire it's the B students and I
tried the last interview or two I would
reach over to the resume and turn it
over and say look I was in a fraternity
I was Commodore the sailing club I'm
actually a human being you could hire me
but they didn't so I got a master's
degree in women's service and then later
on get a PhD I wanted to ask you about
two important people in your life and
that was Fred West and then Harmon algae
and what was it about these men that was
important and as mentors and what did
they teach you about mentoring well Fred
tragically died just a few weeks ago
Fred was trained as an economist he was
in the business school in finance at a
time when finance was pretty simplistic
I might even say moronic and it really
didn't have much economics in it what's
very much really serious empirical work
Fred hired me as his research assistant
one of many actually he was kind of a
factory so I I worked closely with him
and then found that I could take one of
the five fields for my PhD even though
it was in the economics department I
could take in finance so I took finance
as a field fred was just a dynamo I mean
he just and he was so organized he would
teach a seminar by going in with a
recorder and dictating his next book in
effect he would he would have the
graduate students take a subject and
teach the class the subject and happily
he thought that this worked by this guy
named Harry Markowitz might be something
I'd like to teach too one of the classes
which I did and therein lay the story
but he was just fascinated with ideas
and and his goal was he was one of the
very early people to say let's bring the
traditions of economics to bear on
subjects which involve time money now
money later and uncertainty money now
maybe money later and mainstream
economics really didn't deal with either
those issues time to some extent
uncertainty not much at all but he
wanted to bring rigor and the habits of
economic theory
to the field so that was very very
influential in my life my other mentor
was very different I'm an algin who's
still living basically would ask the
fundamental questions and make it simple
I remember his microeconomics ph.d
seminar he taught us that 95 percent of
economic literature is not worth reading
and so therefore he wasn't gonna have
his read any which I had to take the
course from someone else later to learn
something about the field but he started
off so you know musing wrong
you know why don't we buy babies instead
of have adoption and pros and cons
thereof I remember several sessions in
which he was trying desperately to
figure out what profit really is and and
there with Armen it was basically
watching a brilliant mind wrestle with
tough practical problems so it was more
I guess technique and again I can't tell
you he taught us to do this and that and
that but it was sort of an osmosis
process both remarkable men did you did
you what did you learn from them about
when you Laye term entered people with
any specific things that that you had
stuck the remain well I guess as in I
sort of I I critiqued my own work as I
think many researchers do but what I
would do is say over and over again no
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute you know try to play devil's
advocate find other approaches and try
to reduce things to the simplest
possible terms and say ok you did this
modeling you got this resulting here's
this formula and here's the derivative
and blah blah blah what does that mean
in terms that you know anybody on the
street could understand and that's a
hard test but I think it's a useful you
Nobel Prize came out of work that you
stood on your dissertation but you
initially were working on a dissertation
in an entirely different area tell us
about that story well it's it's it's
serendipity 1a I guess I was at the RAND
Corporation and had become interested in
the subject called transfer pricing very
simply your big corporation the widget
department makes widgets and the gadget
department takes the widgets and add
something and produces something else
with them so Department B uses the
output of Department a and corporations
at that time we're trying to establish
some sort of inner accounting internal
accounting and incentive system so a
would quote sell the widgets to the
gadget department and the question was
what price should they sell them for so
that you could evaluate the profit of
both departments in effect and that was
one operations research was just coming
in to to prominence and RAND Corporation
was certainly one of the main places
where it was being developed so I
started working on the problem and I was
using linear programming and various
kinds of approaches to the problem
building on the work of a fellow named
Jack Hearst lifer who at that point was
in Chicago and I had published
internally I ran the first 50 pages of
what I thought was a pretty damn good
dissertation to be and Harmon my
chairman
alchun said well jackers lifer is coming
to UCLA
he's going to work part-time there and
once go introduce yourself he should be
your chairman fine says I I did very
nice fellow gave him my 50 pages he said
give me a week week later I went back
and Jack said you know I don't think
there's a dissertation here which did
not particularly pleased me so I went to
Fred Weston and said Fred what do I do
now and he said remember that work that
you like that Harry Markowitz have done
while Markowitz is coming to Rand
everybody was coming to RAM that week
once you go introduce yourself to him
and maybe you can do something with him
and so very shortly Fred and Armand and
Harry Markowitz and I worked out a deal
that Harry although not on the faculty
was de facto my dissertation chair and
that's how I got into the work which led
to what I've been doing ever since which
I want to touch up now and the work that
you from which you were wore to the
Nobel Prize you sure development to the
capital asset pricing model and like a
lot of great ideas the capital asset the
basic idea behind the capital asset
model seems sort of obvious that riskier
assets should offer better overall
returns than less risky assets what was
it about the capital asset pricing model
that really made it so important the
development of finance well let me sort
of go back one step prior to Harry
Markowitz there was this notion of risk
you know and it got about as
sophisticated as don't put all your eggs
in one basket and I remember a reporter
asking Harry we shared with Merton
Miller the prize in 1990 you know is you
got did you get a Nobel Prize we're
saying to put all your eggs in one
basket do what Harry said yes and the
reporter wandered off puzzled and
therefore confirming you know dick
Taylor and his view and that of the
other quote real scientists that year
that this economic stuff didn't really
have a Nobel Prize and didn't deserve
one anyway then even Harry said let's
quantify risk Jim mentioned standard
deviation that's a measure of risk in
the sense of the width of a probability
distribution of sort of a portfolio
whatever the totality of the things that
you might have in your investment
portfolio would be I then did what in
the dissertation and subsequently
expanded on what anybody trained in
microeconomics would do if
buddy does this what happens when they
all come to market and prices adjust and
the markets clear what Jim offered to
his equilibrium and what I found was
that under some very very simplifying
very rigid simplifying assumptions that
yes Virginia there would be higher
expected return for higher risk but as
Jim said not just any risk if there were
higher expected return for higher risk
we'd all go to Tahoe and have a good
time and make a lot of money the risk
for which there will be a reward if the
markets are functioning at all well when
they want to talk about that is his risk
that as Jim said cannot be diversified
away now I like to when I try to
motivate people for the results of the
CAPM those those results those
implications I quite frankly now in that
and other work prefer to start with Ken
arrows view of the arrow-debreu view of
the world which I won't bore any of you
with I think the result is a little bit
more obvious in in as many ways more
general but the basic idea is if you
want money in times when money is scarce
then you don't have to pay more for it
upfront and if you pay more for it your
expected return is going to be less
that's sort of the core so there's the
two big implications are first yes
Virginia there's a reward for barring
risk but only non diversifiable risk the
second implication is why do you want to
bear that non rewarded risk which says
for God's sakes
diversify and that's really the
intellectual basis for index funds which
I suspect many of you most of you have
heard of and many of you may actually
invest in which are basically funds that
just buy a whole lot of securities
and keep the costs as low as possible I
want to come back to index funds in a
few minutes and I want to touch on one
other aspect of the fun if I if I
understand it correctly the fundamental
essence of capital asset pricing models
are three diversify keep your
transaction cost low and make sure if
you buy a risky investment you are
adequately compensated for the risk can
you expand on those well the first you
know we'd like to say sometimes in
general audiences you know the
principles of real estate three
principles are location location
location in some ways in investments
it's diversified diversified diversify
costs quite frankly you need it's sort
of a look like wahlberg on thisis the
average investor cannot beat the average
investor before costs and if you're out
trying to find hot stocks or the best
new growth fund manager or listening to
Jim Cramer whomever he may be you're
gonna end up bearing extra risk on
average not getting any reward for it
and spending a lot of money in the
bargain so that's sort of that aspect
I've forgotten now number one and number
three what was number three because I
was going to number three number is
number three number three was that you
lost my papers now that that's Prichard
that the return of the investment should
be oh you should I'm sorry
first fire your assets keep your
transaction costs low and make Murphy
buy a risky investment that you
adequately compensated for it yeah okay
that's what I wanted to expand on a
little or argue with you I don't know
how you want to take it but what the
theory says at least broadly if you take
more let's call it market risk economic
risk in other words if you put yourself
in a position to do really badly and bad
times think of it that way
then in some sense you should expect and
that's a mathematical or statistical
concept to do better or another way of
saying it is in the very long run maybe
you will do better but that package
gives you higher expected return and
greater risk and any given period and
this could be a period of a month a year
16 months like the 16 months we just
went through ending in February where
almost every equity investment fell 50
percent in 16 months so if you take risk
in the pursuit of higher expected return
you could get higher return you could
get really higher return you could also
get your head handed to you and a lot of
people forget that so yes maybe in the
long run you're going to do better by
taking risk you can just put it simply
just put your money in the bank
well I used to say where there's no risk
let me restate that I would say I'd be
tempted to say in Treasury bills but who
knows there but but something like that
rather than than even a diversified
equity portfolio let me go back to the
index funds because I wanted to ask you
for something further about that you
suggest that people ought to invest more
of their money through index funds and
less through traditional actively
managed mutual funds what's the
difference between the two strategies
and why is index funding a better
approach for investment
well that that story came out of things
like the capital asset pricing model you
know not very complicated little
mathematical models but no mathematical
models nonetheless but as is so often
the case you can find that you can get
the same conclusion much more simply and
so let me just share with you mmm number
of years ago I published a little op-ed
type piece in the magazine of the
Financial Analysts Federal
so basically a hundred and fifty
thousand practicing investment people
read this because it's their
professional magazine it was called the
arithmetic of active management and it
was embarrassingly simple and the
argument is just very it's very simple
well let me just play it with you if I
may if you'll indulge me imagine that
everybody in this room collectively hold
all the securities in let's say China
since we have somebody from China it's
it's not very well developed mine that's
okay it'll work and we're gonna divide
you into a third over here that you're
gonna be index fund managers got Jim in
the right place and over here the two
thirds of you you're gonna be what we
call active managers I'll tell you what
you do what you do is really simple
you just find out how many shares are
outstanding of every security in China
and if you've got one percent of the
money you buy one percent of every
single company on the Chinese market and
you all do the same thing you do
research you learn about companies you
study industries you visit plants you
lord knows what you do but you find the
companies that are really cheap and you
disdain the company companies that are
really expensive by your lights you do
the same you have different research you
have MBAs from Stanford you have MBAs
from Harvard blah blah blah blah so you
do your things and we call you active
because periodically you change your
mind and you sell things and buy things
so the brokers like you and you get good
seats at football games
okay so you guys are active man as you
guys are passive managers a year passes
the average the total Chinese stock
market returns I don't know ten percent
before costs what does Jim get quick
quick 10 percent 10 10 10 okay what do
you get 20 what do you get -5 over there
is somebody who actually short stocks
whatever that is and lost 80% what have
you so you guys are all over the map
question before costs what is the return
on the average yuan or reven be in this
side of the room what is the average
return before costs and the average you
want or your MMB in this side of the
room you got it after costs these guys
are cheap they don't know anything they
don't do much these people are expensive
they've got degrees from prestigious
business schools they do all this
research and the difference is something
like while Schwab just announced they've
cut their index fund fees on a couple of
index funds to nine cents per year per
hundred dollars the average manager over
here is going to charge $1 per year $400
so after costs the average yuan or MB
over here must must must must must must
underperform over here and here's the
irony if you if you sort of think that
through and say well maybe I'll get the
one who's so smart over here that they
can overcome their costs and beat the
market but then again maybe I'll get him
so let's all go over here but then the
whole system breaks down because we need
these people to be doing their research
and keeping the prices reasonably and in
line with with prospects so it's a kind
of a public good problem in which these
people provide a great service to keep
markets reasonably well functioning so
these people can ride for free it's a
free rider problem
and I've worried over the years that if
I say this to too many people some of
these guys will move over here but they
never do they never do
why do I mean I mean look at all these
so how many of you have seen you know
stop picking magazines I don't care if
it's Forbes fortunes doing in our
business we here's a hot manager here's
a hot strategy here's what's gonna win
next year whoa whoa if markets I mean
markets would have to be crazy to make
it possible for somebody to write an
article in a magazine let alone somebody
to read an article that others have
already read and ex-ante do better
expose somebody's some of these people
are gonna beat these people but ex-ante
you're better off over here but don't
tell too many people traditionally
economists have built their models the
assumption that people behave rationally
when they make investment decisions and
recently economists and psychologists
have challenged that notion challenge
that assumption
is the assumption of rationality is it
an accurate picture of human behavior if
it isn't is there some reason it's still
worth building models based upon
rationality I'm sorry we're out of time
well you know it takes a certain amount
of bravery to appear before you this
time of the world I just finished a book
which actually is very good by justin
fox who's quite careful but the
publisher titled it the myth of the
rational market and then it goes on
something like how jim and i destroyed
the world or something I'm not sure what
and there's a whole spate of things
there has been a strand of research
which we now call behavioral economics
or behavioral finance and it goes
actually way back of which I might say
I've been a fan and I will say that I do
work with cognitive psychologists as a
matter of fact have a project going now
with a recent graduate of the psych
department PhD here and a calling in
London dick Thaler and Cass Sunstein is
co-author in The Book nudge which I
strongly recommend by the way very
accessible talk about economists who
build models of worlds populated by
econ's whereas he builds models of
worlds populated by humans and without
any question the idea that in my work in
the work of people who do what I do
we've never assumed people knew what was
going to happen we have assumed that
they could come up with a list of what
might happen and assign reasonable
probabilities to those different
alternatives so we've never assumed on
missions but we have assumed you know a
degree of predictive power that
certainly not everyone has perhaps no
one has that being said to go to your
last part of your question I did some
work that culminated in a book a couple
of years ago in which I built this for
me very complicated simulation program
where you can create people give them
information and let them trade with each
other and then look at the properties of
the equilibrium and and I was struck and
I well the fact that you can build a
world in which I have some of the
information that's available
Jim has some you have some you know but
we don't know one has all of it I'm a
process it reasonably well you may
process it very badly
you may process it even worse
but in a world in which you got enough
people where somebody has at least some
of the information that's available
concerning what might happen in the
future
even though nobody's anywhere near
perfect and nowhere near rational in
common parlance you can end up with
security prices security prices being
quite similar to those if everybody had
all the information
and processed it right now what you will
not end up with is people's portfolios
or investment strategies being the same
as if they all shared the information
and prosthetists they right and so my
belief and I've devoted a certain amount
of activity over the years in the real
world to trying to help people
institutions and individuals make
sensible investment decisions because
you know anybody who knows anything
about how individuals and institutions
make investment decisions knows that
terrible things are happening out there
unless the markets are absolutely insane
and indeed you can't really justify the
way this investor runs money and the way
that one does and the way that one does
with any possible combination of what
the prospects are so so I think sort of
the bottom line is I'm comfortable with
the two big implications of the CAPM and
subsequent theory much much subsequent
theory that we've talked about you're
probably not going to get rewarded even
in expectation for barring risk that you
can diversify away and you really ought
to diversify widely and keep costs low I
wanted to ask you about bubbles and how
we should in recent years we've seen a
lot of bubbles we had the internet
bubble the housing bubble and it seems
like bubbles have always been with us
and one of the basic premise of classic
economics is that markets tend toward
equilibrium so do bubbles disprove this
premise well this will be self-serving
but if they sell in the models in which
some of us build say well at any given
time given predictions here's how those
predictions will result in prices and
you may get to that equilibrium but that
information will change something will
change in the environment and the
external environment and then you have
to start the markets have to start
moving to a new equilibrium finding most
most of
say when we're teaching this that you
don't really ever probably get to any
equilibrium and the equilibrium you're
moving towards changes from time to time
but if you don't understand what would
happen if you were to get there you I
would argue don't have a clue as to as
to how to understand the actuality the
you know bubbles are interesting
everybody can identify a bubble
afterwards but I you know Bob Shiller
who was one of the the really creative
behaviorists I would call him after
Nixon was impeached did a survey very
carefully controlled to find out how
many people had voted for him and it
turned out you know only 10% of a very
carefully constructed cross Senate that
voted for Nixon and yet somehow or other
he'd won the election
so we all have selective recall I
remember just before the internet bubble
burst being at a sort of a conference of
non economists mostly and they were
asking me how can you justify these
absurd valuations for companies in
Silicon Valley my answer for what it's
worth was well it could be that there is
a small probability that the googles and
Yahoo's I guess it was Yahoo at that
time the yahoos of the world will
totally wipe out business is that have
been around for centuries
I may have probably didn't use General
Motors or Bear Stearns or Lehman
Brothers as an example and if in fact
that happened these companies really
would be worth one huge amount of money
so maybe the market is factoring in a
relatively small probability of of a
great outcome for these companies you
know probably large probability that's
not going to be so wonderful but I did
thankfully said but don't put all your
money in these at most put no more money
in these than they represent today in
terms of market value visa vie the broad
market now of course those who put less
than their representative market value
at the time in would have done a lot
better than those who get even that but
so I do I know as you say bubbles and
and I used to say nobody can predict
bubbles but Bob Shiller got two out of
two he very vocally and in print and in
books predicted a tech bubble and then
he predicted the housing bubble so you
know maybe just maybe he's the exception
and I try to stay in close contact with
Bob I wanted to ask you to step back a
bit in your fellow Nobel laureate Paul
Krugman said that the Great Recession
was a result not only of lacks
regulation in Washington and reckless
risk-taking of Wall Street but also of
faulty theorizing in the act in academia
is he right and and what do you think
that economists can learn from this era
and the mistakes
well pollen is in the initial column in
the op-ed piece in The Times where he
nicely summarized Justin Fox's book that
when I told you about did reference
Justin but in the long op-ed Sunday
magazine as I recall he forgot to
mention Justin which is not to say Paul
hasn't said that before and since I
think there are two issues a lot of that
debate if you will and maybe it's no
longer a debate has to do with
macroeconomics no I'm not a macro
economist I've read some of the work by
George Akerlof
and Bob Shiller again and you know the
debate between but just just simply put
there was Keynes
and following Keynes there was a sort of
an anti Keynes movement in
macroeconomics which had some of this
efficient market super rational flavour
that Keynes said look and if you get
trouble government should spend a lot of
money and do a lot of stimulation etc
etcetera to get you out Keynes of being
the sort of the intellectual giant in
economics during the 30s and then
subsequently people said well no wait a
minute if people in the markets know
that if we get in this kind of trouble
the government is going to do that then
people will have already taken that into
account and it won't work anymore I'm
really oversimplifying but that's about
my level of understanding of the field
anyway and so a lot of what Paul and
others are saying is it's really an
attack on the assumption of hyper
rationality if you want to call it that
and the macro economics literature Bob
Lucas being sort of a Nobel Prize winner
a kind of a clear case in point I think
on the financial economic side which to
me means investments and derivatives and
kinds of things Jim Van Horn does it's a
little bit more complex but I think my
simple view of it is that as as Jim very
nicely put it if you have people who can
win and maybe win big by taking a lot of
risk and not lose or not lose much if it
turns out badly because either they just
go on to another job or you and I the
taxpayers bailed them out then you're
gonna have two things people to the
extent that they can get away with it
legally will take a lot of risk and you
do that by borrowing a lot of money by
using
Everage either explicitly or implicitly
and on the way up it's a great ride and
we've all seen what a great ride it was
on the way up for lots of institutions
and individuals but then when things
turn bad it can get very very ugly now
we knew this in the traditional banking
industry and we regulated we ensured we
regulated we inspected and while that
process is far from perfect that's not
really where the problem was what
happened
those clever people in the financial
industry many of whom we trained found
ways to do that sort of thing in what is
called broadly the shadow banking
industry which was not regulated and
indeed it is less regulated it was until
recently then it had been just a 10-15
years before we actually softened what
little regulation there was in a number
of domains and so financial people did
what financial people do they're really
smart there are a lot of very smart
people in this industry and they figured
out a way to take a lot of risk so that
if things turned out well they'd become
fabulously wealthy and if they didn't
yeah and for the biggest ones you and I
we all bailed them out I've bailed them
out are still to a non-trivial extent
bailing them out and there's something
desperately wrong in that so if you were
a regulator today are there one or two
things that you would immediately do
that really are you know things that are
really stuck in you're about immediate
action that you would take if your
regulator well the simple things are
capital requirements disclose your
standardization trading things
explicitly where there's some hope of
figuring out what they might be worth
because transactions are taking place
for derivatives with regard to
investment banks and
and hedge funds and what-have-you
requiring a certain amount of capital
which limits to some extent the risk and
not allowing certain you know leverage
somehow measured below such himself but
to be perfectly frank it's just not a
fair contest no matter how dedicated the
people in the regulatory institutions
may be they're just they can't compete
they can't move fast enough to deal with
these very very very smart people who go
into big finance and so I'm reluctantly
joining the that have joined the camp
that says if it's too big to fail or to
systemic to fail then it's too big or
systemic to exist you've got to find
some level and say will regulate
everybody as best we can but nobody from
now on out gets bailed out and since we
know that if you're too big or too
interconnected that's a hollow threat we
just not let people get that big and
connected and will there be costs yes
but and again I I have no notion how you
do it executive compensation
what do you how do you think that should
be attacked well it's easy to say it's a
kind of a sideshow it certainly is a
motivating force on the part of top
executives in terms of the risk they
take in their organizations you know I'm
I should tell you you might as well know
I'm a knee-jerk liberal Democrat who
believes free markets are can be really
helpful and so I'm I have nothing but
cognitive dissonance and schizophrenic I
don't know what I am or where I am but
ask me the question again I was so and I
was so embarrassed to tell you that I've
forgotten where I was going okay never
mind
one of the things that you you when we
spoke before you threw out sort of a
hand grenade that I'll lay out here
tonight and you said that under existing
social security systems seniors don't
bear their fair share of the risk of
economic downturns and I wondered if
you'd expand on that they this is I mean
your mother didn't want you to be a
physician nor did she want you to be a
politician clearly I'll tell one more
story about my mother since you brought
her up again after the after the market
crash in 1987 somebody in the Wall
Street Journal got hold of me I was in
an airport somewhere the pay phone was
that recall and they said well how do
you explain the fact that the stock
market dropped 20% in one day I think
that's depends on which part of the
stock market and I said well yeah and
then I said well I don't know but it's
really weird whereupon the Wall Street
Journal published you know my one line
comment wait a minute you know that was
pre prize but you know distinguished
professor at Stanford it says it's
really weird and my mother my mother
said three degrees nine years in college
the sale and what all you can say is
it's weird okay
full stop back to the question which is
was it bad bearing their fair share of
social well years ago and then it's been
several years ago it occurred to me that
when you think about Social Security or
Medicare or more broadly the division of
the pie between those who are working
and in a sense produce it and those who
are retired and in a sense you know are
living off the production of those who
are producing the pie when you think
about that division we had a system
under the old traditional Social
Security and the old kind of pension
where you made no decisions you went to
work you retired you got a check you
died your spouse got a check you know
in that regime if the pie shrunk for
example as it has in the last in this
great recession the old folks said not
my problem
I've got my checks and if their Social
Security they're indexed for inflation
no problem there if you're in CalPERS or
a public defined benefit pension plan
indexed for inflation and that that
didn't seem as though it was the right
way to do it if you go back to the old
agrarian days when the farmers supported
the old folks on the farm if there was a
bad year everybody shared in the misery
and in some sense when you had ten
percent of the population retired let's
say maybe that worked so the risk was
born basically by the workers did widely
oversimplify and the retired people
didn't bear much of any economic risk
but as the demographics move us
inexorably to fifteen percent twenty
percent in some countries more than 20
percent retired it just is not an
efficient division of risk there has to
be in some sensible societal arrangement
some sharing of the risk of bad times by
the old folks not proportionately
perhaps and not by everybody some old
folks can choose perhaps to bear no such
risk others can choose to bear
proportionate or more but the old rigid
system just didn't seem to me to make
any sense so so I concluded in the early
90s really that the move from the
traditional pension to 401ks and things
of that sort
kind of pension system that we've had at
Stanford forever where you put money in
and you decide within limits how much to
put in what you get in retirement
depends on what the investments are
worth that you to some extent chose that
kind of system is going to eventually
dominate at least a substantial part of
retirement saving
what is the right breakdown I don't know
should people be allowed to put all
their money in stocks or in an oil fund
I kind of think not some of the things I
do in industry I get some glimpse into
what people really do with these kinds
of plans and and it's it's appalling
what people do they put you know half or
more of their retirement savings in the
stock of their own company so if you
work for Enron General Motors you know
well I have bad news
we've lost your job you'll never find
another one and the other bad news is
your retirement savings are worth
nothing that's crazy that's nuts
and and and then they put their money in
mutual funds that charge high expenses
and have absolutely no track record or
any reason to believe in the future they
can outperform these folks
so people may and they don't save enough
it's just it's a there's a whole litany
of Horrors and events like these how
often are you buttonholed about personal
investment decisions well I've gone
through most of my adult life having
people ask me for the hot stop stock tip
or the best mutual fund and that always
elicits my little well I've devoted my
life to building models which show that
neither I nor for that matter anybody
else can answer that question for you go
to this side of the room but I've
noticed recently to the extent I dare
talk to groups like this that people are
not asking that because I think you now
understand financial economists are the
last people you want to ask to predict
the future
let me before we take questions from the
audience I wanted to ask you two
questions one is the day that you won
the Nobel Prize did you have any clue
that this was about to unfold and how
did it change your life how did that day
go and how did it change your life the
day the call came Kathy my wife was next
to Jim Van Horn here and I were at a
conference in Tucson and the phone rang
at 4 o'clock and they very somebody with
a quite thick accent said well I'm
pleased to announce that you won the
Nobel Prize and I thought sure you know
which of my colleagues thought this was
really funny and there was another
complication that some guy wanted me to
talk in Europe and he'd been calling it
inopportune times I thought it might be
him any event so we turned on CNN and
within five minutes they carried the
story and I would say it was about 60%
right you know they had some of the
names of Harry Markowitz Martin Miller
our affiliations wrong but every five
minutes they would get it closer and
closer so we've we finally figured no to
your first question did we anticipate it
no I have not even pay in paying
attention to the fact that it was the
time I think those of us in financial
economics have pretty well figured that
our field would not be included by the
committee in the definition of economics
which perhaps they rue the day now that
they did include it and for a couple of
reasons people passed over it cetera so
I just haven't thought you know that
that I would have even had a shot at it
and we have this lovely we sent for room
service and we sat on the little patio
or deck outside our room we watched the
Sun Rise over Tucson it's very calm and
quiet and then all hell broke loose so
it certainly changed our lives then it
did not change my life at Stanford one
iota my colleagues had no more respect
for me afterwards
but they did start saying almost
instantly well what have you done lately
the for quite a while I would get or you
get asked questions about things you
know nothing about and as some of you
may know once in a while a Nobel Prize
winner will actually think they know
something about which they know nothing
and it embarrassed themselves and others
I mean most of us who who are so honored
have been working hopefully deeply in a
very very narrow area and so we're about
the last person to ask about disarmament
I remember I had a call from an Italian
journalist a few days after the
announcement and he said what do you
think about should Russia do this and
you know big European questions that
European journalists want to ask and
finally he said well do you know
anything about anything interesting and
I said no and he hung up but I try to
try to stay in my area you do get
invited less so now you do get invited
to give talks to groups and whereas
before when you're invited to give a
talk it was will you speak about the
capital asset pricing model or depth
securitization and but the very often
invitations that would you come speak
about whatever you'd like to which
there's a lot nicer there are a number
of young students in the audience and I
wanted to ask you if you had one piece
of advice to young person thinking about
a career as an academic economist what
would that be well I'm too far out of
touch with the industry or a profession
to to know how different it may be now
obviously and I was I was in the perfect
place first of all I was born in a year
when very few people were born so there
wasn't a lot of competition no matter
what you wanted to do
which was very helpful plus there was a
huge huge influx of faculty positions
because of a huge influx of students
post-war so academics was a growth
industry in my era it was it's there was
an incredible career I'm you know and if
if it's even a pale shadow now of what
what it was in my era I would say why
would you ever want to do anything else
now I did try to keep one foot in the
real world and one in academics
sometimes that get a little more weight
on one than the other both because I
wanted to test some of my academic ideas
in the real world and influence people
who made real decisions and because
knowing something about the real world I
thought informed my academic work so I
had it I kind of have the best of all
worlds but I think you know you've got a
you've got to find whatever it is that
turns you on to be blatant about it and
then desperately try to find a way to
make a living doing it and discovery I'm
evening you know one word why is being
an academic wonderful because you get to
discover things and that's that's always
been it for me teaching is fine grading
is onerous teaching is wonderful but you
miss teaching I don't miss grading I try
to teach in various forums you know
fairly often we live in Carmel so I with
a colleague John Watson a mathematician
who's in the audience have done some
work with Naval Postgraduate School
including thesis direction and teaching
some operations research sections try to
keep my hand in it I do short course
things at Stanford I view this as
teaching and I like to talk to I'd like
to talk to people in the industry and I
like to talk whenever I can with him
moderation still sharp thank you thank
you okay nothing up subject that you
might regard is out of your domain
climate change
and how well-informed markets may or may
not be able to acquire the external
information that we have assumed out of
existence for half a century are we
going to be able to get the kind of
information that we need about the real
prices of what's going on on our planet
here in time to make the kinds of
adjustments that I am the growing number
of fantastic scientists are saying we
need to make well you're quite right I
can't answer that question the best I
could give you would be a very bad
translation of what Steve Tru has told
me over the years and and some of my
other friends who really know about the
technical issues but let me say
something about the economic issues all
the aspects I think that you're probably
thinking of under the rubric climate
change involved what economists call
externalities that basically I do
something and it hurts you now Ronald
Coase who won a prize number of years
ago in economics showed again like so
many important ideas it's kind of
obvious well if I own the rights to
pollute your air and make you sick
then you will pay me not to do it if in
fact it makes sense or if you own the
rights so that if I want to pollute your
air and make you sick then I have to pay
you
and so Coast the Coase theorem says the
key thing is somebody has to have
property rights in this activity and at
least that's a necessary condition for a
reasonable equilibrium to the extent
that climate change at a certain level
of a certain type is going to cause
devastation somebody needs to be told
well if you continue to do what you're
doing with
or coal or whatever you got to pay and
you've got to pay big-time in fact you
have to pay enough that perhaps if the
devastation is too great you just won't
do it at all or at least you'll
seriously limit it so we need to get
property rights established wherever we
can and there are two main approaches
brewing it around to this that you've
read about one is I'll just use carbon
as an example of carbon tax you want to
emit carbon again I don't understand the
physics
it'll cost you this much per liter or
whatever the measure may be and you pay
that say to the government and the
government can use that to do whatever
they want with it and you set that price
high enough so there is what at least
you the government / scientists think is
a reasonable equilibrium between the
good things you can get by burning coal
and the bad things you get by burning
coal so there's some some balance point
now that puts a big burden on the
government to set that carbon price
that's one approach the other which
you've heard a lot about is
cap-and-trade you say well I want no
more than X units of carbon and I will
grant each of you who now perhaps
produce some carbon property rights to
emit a certain amount free of charge you
can't do any more unless you buy rights
from someone else and if you do less you
can sell the excess that you're not
producing to someone else so they're
both ways of getting a price associated
with the external externality and
getting something closer to a sensible
outcome I happen to favor as I think
many economists do the tax because the
cap-and-trade is open to all kinds of
political shenanigans as to who gets
what amounts of quotas but again you can
show that under certain circumstances
you can replicate the results of one
with the other
the distribution of income and wealth
can be very different but I I think like
most academics let me say am I in
convinced that that all these
environmental externalities we have too
much of them and it's not surprising to
an economist because they're free so we
got to find a way to charge for doing
these things and the science is going to
have to tell us how much to charge and
to put it again overly simplistic way
but while you're not that question you
see the reverses stocks versus split
stocks like some microsystem last year
they reverse the stocks they have a put
four in one instead of like most of
what's good for the investment or what's
bad for investors okay do I you're
talking about something called stock
splits reverse stock splits this goes
way back actually in the literature
there was this notion that if you have a
hundred shares of ownership in your
company and you take back every share
and you give them and stab two shares so
now there are two hundred shares
representing the same ownership in the
same company that somehow other the
value of the two hundred shares will be
greater than the value of the hundred
shares was and you might say well that
just shows how sophisticated economics
is that makes no sense at all well it
did make no sense at all it does make no
sense at all people over the years have
done empirical studies trying as best
they can for to control for other
influences on stock prices to make that
point and there are some subtle
arguments but they're there second third
and fourth order that's something that
people like to do I guess when they have
nothing better to do it's just it's just
it's not a very important phenomenon
either way question over here
yes well you refer to index funds I
believe you were referring to well
diversified index funds like yes thank
you life under thank you a world index
fund yes I'd like to hear your comments
about specialized funds like a energy
index fund or a financial index fund
asinine in a word I mean you can say
well if I work in the tech industry
maybe I don't want to hold a
proportionate share of everything in the
world maybe I want to be a little light
on tech stocks because after all my
human capital is in tech and so you can
say ah I know how to do that we'll buy
that world market portfolio referred to
which I happen to love even though you
can't find one to buy it's sort of
everything out there bond stocks you
name it but maybe I'll buy that and then
I'll take are you ready for this a short
position in the tech index fund to
basically bring down my stock tech
exposure so you can make some subtle
arguments but by and large people use
those specialized from energy funds this
fund that fund for betting there's sort
of two things you can do in the security
markets you can invest or you can bet
and you really need to think about the
extent to which you're doing one versus
the other you're betting you're betting
that somebody else has got it wrong
and you're able to buy something that's
under priced or sell something that's
overpriced and you're putting a big
burden on that assumption if you invest
you're just taking your proportionate
share of what makes sense in terms of
saving for the future whether it's in
low risk or high risk but again when I
say index funds I mean cheap and highly
diversified unless there's a very
compelling reason to do something else
and don't be fooled there are some
expensive index funds it's hard to
conceive but there are
look at the expense ratio before you
invest I just had a question more about
academics and your experience when you
introduce you know the cap M idea which
was at the time a revolutionary would
you would your advice be to two graduate
students in economics or even other
fields about you know introducing a new
idea that may challenge some of the
establishment ideas and how would you
advise young graduates who to sort of
maneuver their way in a field where they
might find resistance to some ideas a
challenge okay it's my situation at that
point was a little different in that
there really wasn't a well-developed
field of financial economics in other
words there wasn't much of a received
wisdom about how to deal with
uncertainty and movement over time etc
etc using tools of economics so to the
extent that there were people thinking
in that way and there certainly were
this was not I suppose surprising a
revolutionary because there wasn't you
know a body of work to revolt against oh
it wasn't a paradigm shift it was of
course very revolutionary in the
investment industry another anecdote
because I think anecdotes sometimes work
better a colleague of mine at Stanford
Paul Kutner who died tragically young
published a book of papers called a
random walk down Wall Street which
basically said you can't predict the
market or individual securities or
industry stocks or what have you he was
invited to talk to 500 people from The
Wall Street establishment an industry
group in New York and the person who
introduced him who I'm sure was
fabulously wealthy Paul was at MIT at
the time said well professor Kohner
if you're so smart why aren't you rich
whereupon Paul said well I have a
question for you
mr. whatever his name was if you're so
rich why aren't you smart and and and it
took us about those of us in academics
who tried to influence industry takes
about five years to get over that that
one little remark and establish contact
with practice but more importantly I
mean I do try to shake up the investment
establishment I have a paper that was
just accepted that I'm revising now for
publication in this journal I mentioned
to you that 160,000 investment
practitioners around the world get I'm
not saying they read it but they get in
and just as they absolutely hated the
arithmetic of active management piece a
lot of them going to really hate this
one because it argues that the policies
for asset allocation that almost all
large institutional investors have and
almost all balanced mutual funds and
almost all what are called lifecycle or
target date funds and really you don't
make a lot of sense and it's just a
typical economist thing you can't add
them up you know it's the it's it's
another version of playing the game of
everybody in the room but at least it
got through the review process and the
editor loved it so so we'll see but my
guess is that's gonna stir them up but
most academics they're gonna send
courses it's so tribulus why do you even
publish it but I would say stick by your
guns the other thing I will tell you
that might be your experience although
now with the internet and online
publication I'm not sure how this works
I published that article it took three
years it was rejected by the way and I
had to appeal for new referees so
there's a cautionary tale if your
article is rejected don't despair keep
trying but I published it and I sat by
the phone at the time at the University
of Washington waiting for the phone to
ring off the hook because I said well
this is clearly going to be the best
I ever published may not be good but
it'll be the best Oliver do and nobody
called zero nada eventually people
started trying to counter it and in that
era at least I didn't realize people
don't even open a journal for a year or
so and then they read the abstracts and
maybe they skim the paper so in that era
took a long time for paper to have any
impact
now obviously you put something on the
internet as soon as you have the first
draft but on the other hand there's so
much to read it's not at all clear to me
that it may be the same I don't know but
it's it's very easy for a discipline and
a lot of the critics of financial
economics have made this point to start
just getting in its own little world you
know you build a model and then you
adapt the model that was built by the
last guy and pretty soon everything is
sort of self referential and you've
totally lost touch with anything useful
but it's such a nice little game in a
nice little world that you've
constructed so I think it's always good
to say at the end of the day or at the
end of the article now now does this
make any sense
yeah sure these equations came from
those equations and I got the math right
in between but does it really make any
sense and what's it telling me and do I
believe it or should you believe it
that's one of those things that can't
help me at all but that's that's what I
would say but over here thank you for
your time that was very interesting
thank you
I just finished the book intelligent
portfolio so I know you're involved with
the company financial pensions and I
just wondered is there anything that
came out of that data or working with a
company that surprised you were altered
your thinking or confirmed suspicions
that you would help well I don't want to
make this a commercial I will thank Pat
by the way for putting my wife's website
in them panned out and if you haven't
got one you should get it and go see it
because she's an artist
which is what keeps me semi sane
the financial engines is a company that
a group of us started in 1996 to try to
help individuals in 401k plans and plans
like Stanford's make sensible decisions
in terms of investing their savings for
retirement through one of those vehicles
I guess I have learned a that it's that
it's hard to to build you know the whole
philosophy of financial engines wasn't
is very low marginal cost so that people
don't have to spend much money getting
good predictions good advice good this
good that but at high fixed cost
we're in Liza another story I guess what
I've learned is people really do very
foolish things not all by any means but
as I said earlier and to the extent that
I thought that people needed help I
guess I now think they need help even
more than I perhaps thought going in and
I guess the other thing may be standing
way back is that it's not as simple as
we thought it was and that's true of the
field of investments academic investment
research as well here's just an example
of that according to the kinds of
assumptions that were made by say large
pension funds and others the chance of
the markets around the world going down
fifty percent in 16 months time was
something like one out of three thousand
and of course they did and there's been
a lot of soul-searching on the part of
people making probabilistic forecasts is
it really one out of three thousand and
we just got really unlucky more than
once in the last you know 50 years or
maybe going forward at least we better
start predict
there's a higher chance than that not
one out of two but maybe one out of a
thousand maybe one out of a hundred who
knows so so a lot of people are again
thinking rethinking what they should use
as probabilities for different
investment outcomes when they try to
tell wrong if you keep doing what you're
doing with your 401 K here's the chance
you will have a happy retirement Ron
will never retire so and so I think
again nobody can prove it we're talking
about the theory in financial economics
is about the future probabilities of
things that could happen in the future
it's not about what happened in the past
and people in the industry and academics
to a major extent have taken the easy
way out and assume that the frequency
with which things happen in the past is
probably a good enough assumption as to
the probability of similar things
happening in the future and I think you
know we're all remembering to go back
and read the beginning papers and
textbooks that said no no it's about the
future and you've got to use whatever
information you get your hands on to
make the best probabilistic forecasts of
outcomes in the future when you project
an investment outcome range or when you
advise somebody as to how to invest and
save so a lot of soul-searching going on
in the investment counseling investment
consulting investment forecasting
industry at least the part that actually
uses some of the theories developed in
academics and I might say a lot of first
class financial economics has been
developed over many years now in the
industry as well as in academics we have
time for one more question how would you
explain warren buffett is he smarter
than anybody else
oh good I can answer with an anecdote
which many many years ago and it was
many Jim will probably remember when
Business School has an advisory council
of movers and shakers in the business
world that come together and I've always
suspected they come together to form
cartels but I don't know that any way
they come together to advise the school
and and I was a young professor at
Stanford Business School and RJ Miller
our then Dean said well I'd like you to
address this group and tell him about
this efficient market capital asset
pricing model stuff so I did and
finished an RJ turned to me and said
well okay how do you explain Warren
Buffett up here and Warren Buffett was
sitting up there and I said I believe I
said well I think Warren Buffett is a
three sigma event three sigma for those
of you know about probability
distributions is a very rare occurrence
and warren subsequently told that story
and i think it got up to five sigma in
the retelling here's the problem you
know if you have you know a hundred
thousand monkeys no none of them will
type the Gettysburg Address
but one of them is going to have a
stellar investment record
and how do you really know if that's
because that was a really smart monkey
or one who was repeatedly lucky now
Warren has not always made money
he's lost money that being said I
personally think he's really smart and I
don't think if you're in financial
economics you have to believe that there
is nobody who can beat the market more
often than not but I think it's a
helpful to believe there are very few of
them and it's really hard to identify
who they are before the fact and besides
which they may charge you a lot of money
and I think I'd like to end on that for
more please visit us at stanford.edu